This is Emily. Oh, my name's Emily Gosu and I'm an artist.
What is your name?
Some of you may remember that a couple of years ago we did a story about Emily
where she had been hit by a truck, gone into a coma,
and then her boyfriend at the time, Allen, uh,
had brought her back by writing on her hand.
She's writing her name on the poem of mine.
Of all the stories we've ever done,
I think this one has gotten the most response. And when we left that story,
Emily had emerged from the coma and begun to recover, but she was blind.
Totally blind, right? Yeah. I like no light any and nothing coming in. No. Okay.
Needless to say, it was a very big adjustment.
I just know I just had to develop my own ways to navigate throughout the world
and chest myself and, and being a visual artist,
she had to develop new ways to draw.
I had crayons and if you draw the crayons hard enough,
you can feel the wax on the paper. Um,
yeah.
But then one day in the summer of 2012 she gets a call from the lighthouse
school and New York City. The lighthouse school. Yeah,
it's a school for the blind.
Her mom had found out that they were trying out this brand new technology.
I think they were doing this study for the FDA, very experimental.
And her mom signed her up. Long Story Short, uh,
Emily shows up to the lighthouse school one day and walks into this room and a
guy named Ed gives her this thing. He gives me the device. Can you describe it?
I mean, is it a big helmet or no, it's not.
It's just like a regular pair of sunglasses though.
They were a little heavier than your normal sunglasses. She says,
cause right on the front,
like on the bridge of the nose was a little camera playing forward and then a
task to the sunglasses was a little wire that ran out of the camera and down to
this little square piece of metal thing.
It's made out of titanium and it's just like the size of a postage stamp or a
little bit thicker though.
Ed explained to her that the little piece of titanium was filled with thousands
of electrodes and what was going to happen is that the camera was going to
convert images into patterns of electricity on that little square.
So he told her to take a little square, place it on your tongue,
put it right on the center of your tongue and close your mouth.
So I put it on and they [inaudible]
turn it on. Um, and it was like,
it started to tick off.
Imagine a lot of Coca Cola,
like a lot of bubbles on your tongue and always like quickly,
perfectly feelings.
The idea behind this thing, according to the science writer, Sam Kean,
author of the tale of the duly neurosurgeons is that we actually see with our
brain, not our eyes.
I mean it might seem like our eyes are doing the seeing and our ears doing the
hearing and our fingers and tongue note of the tasting, the touching.
But that's actually not how it works.
Each of our senses sends signals into the brain as electricity,
little blips on nerves.
And it is the brain that then converts those little blips into what you perceive
as a sight or a sound or a smell. No, obviously someone who is blind,
their retina is not sending those signals anymore.
But what if there is another way to get signals for light and dark and color
into our brain?
In all of our brains,
there are lots and lots of pathways going from every part of the brain to every
other part of the brain.
And normally your brain isn't using those pathways even though they exist.
It's like there's a road there, but it's shut down and traffic can be on it.
But
what if you could open up some of those routes?
Let me, uh, sit with it on for an hour or two hours.
Emily says, at first she had no idea what was happening.
She would just swivel her head around and feel the patterns on her tongue chain.
And every time I looked around, he'd say, oh, that's his chair.
That's the door best me. [inaudible]
that's your mom. And it went on like this for awhile.
Ed showed her a ball and a square plastic banana and nothing was really
happening for her except for the prickly feelings on her tongue.
But then there was this moment,
ed had this really long styrofoam broad and he last day in front of me,
you moved it up and down in front of my face and I was like,
oh my God, what's that? Suddenly she says, she just saw it.
I was like, oh my God. It's just happen on his own.
What did it look like in some of my mind is I looked like a long white,
skinny stick. Could you see the texture of the sticker? Um,
no. I couldn't see texture.
I couldn't see in three dimensions. It was very flat.
It was kind of like that kid's toy light, right?
Yeah.
So imagine like a black screen and little tiny white dots
all arranged in a line.
Hello.
So Emily was allowed to keep the brain port device for about a year and a half.
And during that time the light bright resolution of it did get better.
As your brain learned to speak tongue.
It was awesome when I saw the people moving in and one of the things that really
struck me in our conversation was I asked her about this video that her mom had
sent me, showing her wearing the device in walking down the street.
She told me that usually,
you know now that she's blind when she's walking down the streets of New York
City,
especially uptown where the streets are a lot wider.
She says people see her in her white cane and walk a really wide circle around
her.
So I uh, yeah,
I hardly ever notice other people walk here on me.
It feels like I'm just walking alone.
I can always hear the chatbot and the sound of topic,
but not other people.
When she says when she put the device on and put that little sensor on her
tongue,
the sidewalk came alive. I thought it was amazing.
Like,
I didn't know this many people were on the street at the same time as me,
and now they're all, they're all there again,
which you described them in a way that sounded
almost like a painting,
like really soft lashes.
Everything was really soft,
like soft flashes of ink that could move.
Yeah.
There's walking and I could see their legs moving and I could see them,
their gait, but I couldn't see them clearly.
Like I couldn't see their features or what are they wearing?
A shirt or shorts or a dress or pants.
I just like see their shadows and every now and then I see the light cast sit on
them. Really? Yeah.
I've imagined somehow I'm like underwater creatures.
Squishy jellyfish like, yeah.
Yeah. Like lighting. Yeah.
[inaudible] yeah. Like
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and that for Emily is what it's like to translate the city with your tongue.
New York City becomes this, uh,
hazy c of walking fish that make their way along in the sunshine.